und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen allen die Webseite des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes ist heute
mehrfach in die Knie gegangen überlastet
denn das Informationsbedürfnis ist hoch
was tut sich da gerade am Himmel über
Deutschland vor schwersten Gewittern mit
massiven Folgen gab vor Tornados hatten
die Meteorologen gewarnt allerdings und
das liegt in der Natur der Sache lassen
sich gerade diese besonders starken
Unwetter eben nicht geographisch ganz
präzise Vorhersagen es gab
Wetterwarnungen für fast das ganze Land
die Situation heute abend schildert
Christian von Rechenberg
das kam eben vom Himmel Hagelkörner
hagelbällchen eigentlich und spätestens
jetzt war klar warum der Wetterdienst
heute warnte gehen Sie nicht ins Freie
schließen Sie Fenster und Türen achten
Sie auf Gegenstände die herumfliegen
tief Lambert rückt an nahm heute vor
allem die Region um Kassel ins Visier
ein Naturspektakel Superzellen am Himmel
sie bringen fast aus dem nichtsorganen
Wassermassen bis zu 100 Liter pro
Quadratmeter waren heute möglich was das
bedeutet sieht man ab dem Nachmittag in
den sozialen Medien innerhalb von zwei
Stunden rufen in Kassel 800 Menschen die
112 brauchen die Feuerwehr weil ihre
Keller vorlaufen Autofahren entweder
unmöglich oder ein paar bankspiel Busse
und Bahnen stellen den Betrieb ein Gott
lob bislang keine Verletzten
höchste unwetterwarnstufe in Deutschland
gekommen war das Tief aus Frankreich es
zieht in der Nacht und weiter nach Osten
ohne an Kraft zu verlieren welche Kraft
das wurde auch den Menschen in
Rheinland-Pfalz heute schlagartig klar
eben noch drückende Hitze Minuten später
Sturm und stürzende Bäume in Kreis
Kochen Zell trifft einer auf die
Fahrbahn als dort ein Kleinlaster
unterwegs ist passiert auch hier aus ein
paar Beulen nichts
gegen Abend kommt das Unwetter in
Niedersachsen an hinterlässt Spuren in
der Region Hildesheim als hätten riesen
hier gewütet Baumwipfel verstreut keinen
Winkel ausgelassen der kann hilft sich
selbst und Hilfe wird überall gebraucht
in Hildesheim auch wofür einen Fahrer
ohne die Feuerwehr nichts mehr
weitergeht der unterwegs war trotz aller
Warnungen wie so viele die so ein
Unwetter nicht erwartet hatten
[Musik]
es war Wahnsinn es hat auf einmal
angefangen Bäume sind rausgerissen
überall Überschwemmungen man musste gar
nicht wohin so schnell mülltonnen sind
durch die Gegend geflogen also es war
schon hart und es hört nicht auf hart
zusammen aktuell kommen aus dem Harz aus
Sachsen-Anhalt diese Bilder Blankenburg
rette sich wer kann
vor dem Regen vor dem Hagel vor dem
Wasser
der Weiler ist es von der Bahn
Verspätungen und Zugausfälle vor allem
im Osten und im Norden was in diesen
Stunden schon vom Himmel kommt wird in
der Nacht in ganz Bayern und Brandenburg
erwartet
was für Bilder wir haben es gerade
gesehen Sachsen-Anhalt wir gehen jetzt
nach Magdeburg live zu Andreas Weise
Andreas guten Abend wie ist die
Situation aktuell
ja Moment fängt es wieder etwas heftiger
an hier in Magdeburg zu regnen wir
hatten hier vor gut anderthalb Stunden
den Höhepunkt des Unwetters bis jetzt da
war es tiefschwarze Nacht und wir haben
wir haben
wir haben tschuldigung wir haben
sozusagen die gesehen dass es hier ein
heftiges Gewitter gab heftige Regenfälle
allerdings keinen Hagel und bisher
scheint die sachsen-anhaltische
Landeshauptstadt ganz glimpflich davon
gekommen zu sein aber was wir aus dem
Harz hören wir haben es ja gerade im
Stück auch gesehen die Bilder sind
heftig die A36 bei Blankenburg ist nach
einer Schlammlawine gesperrt und aktuell
hören wir auch das in der Höhe von
Bernburg auch wieder die das Unwetter
zugenommen hat das ist also alles auch
hier noch nicht ganz vorbei in
sachsen-anhaltsweise ZDF Magdeburg
vielen Dank es ist noch nicht ganz
vorbei das ist das Stichwort unser ZDF
Meteorologe ist bei uns was denn guten
Abend da könnte noch was kommen oder wie
ist die Lage aktuell
einen gewittertiv also ein
gewitterzentrum direkt zu das haben wir
eben auf dem radarfilm schon gesehen und
ähm auch über Nacht wird ja noch
weitergehen und wir können uns das auch
mal gerne genauer anschauen wo denn
diese superzahlen zu sehen waren und wir
sehen hier wie mächtig und wie groß die
sind also da zwei Zellen allein fast
ganzen Norddeutschland und im Süden
ebenfalls da kommt es jetzt nach und das
hat noch nicht aufgehört und wird sich
weiter fortsetzen also ich verstehe Dich
richtig es gibt keine Entwarnung was ist
denn in der bevorstehende Nacht zu
erwarten ja keine Entwarnung auf jeden
Fall und im Norden wird es ja weiter
regnen Nordrhein-Westfalen Niedersachsen
da wird ja noch längere Zeit schütten
muss man sagen und diese
Gewittertätigkeit die setzt sich im
Osten Deutschlands weiter fort also es
zieht auch noch auf Berlin weiter zu
nachdem es Magdeburg passiert hat und
auch im Süden Deutschlands diese Zellen
die wir gerade gesehen haben auf dem
Bild ähm die zeigen uns eben da ist noch
eine Menge Musik drin und diese warme
Luft die kommt ja aus dem Mittelmeer zu
uns dann noch die Frage ist nachdem viel
größeren Zusammenhang des ganzen die
sich natürlich in dieser Tage immer
wieder stellt was von dieser Wetterlage
ist Wetter und was ist Klima erst einmal
ist das ja Wetter was das was da
passiert aber wir müssen ja schon sagen
dass sich ja
Atmosphäre verändert hat und diese
Parameter sich verändert haben in der
Atmosphäre dementsprechend werden diese
Gewitter auch immer heftiger das sagen
ja auch die Wissenschaftler und letzten
Endes wie schon gesagt die Luft kommt
aus dem Mittelmeer und das Mittelmeer
ist derzeit zu warm also irgendwo muss
diese Wärme bleiben und wenn Sie zu uns
geführt wird gibt es eben diese heftigen
Gewitter also das hängt ganz eng
miteinander zusammen vielen Dank für
diese Informationen heute Abend die
Klimakrise betrifft uns alle auf diesem
Planeten diese Gewissheit dürfte langsam
auch bei den letzten einsickern die
internationale Politik verspricht jetzt
jedenfalls nichts weniger als eine
fundamentale Neuausrichtung der globalen
Entwicklungshilfe ein neuer finanzpackt
orientiert an der Tatsache dass die
Länder des sogenannten globalen Südens
noch mal stärker von der Klimakrise
betroffen sind als wir hier
da ist eine enorme Kluft entstanden in
einer Welt die dringend mehr
Zusammenarbeit bräuchte aus Paris wo
über 100 Staaten miteinander beratend
wer die Welt verschmutzt soll dafür
bezahlen es ist eine klare Forderung mit
der mit Siedlung Eltern nach Paris
gereist ist die 25-Jährige Philippina
hat die Folgen des Klimawandels hautnah
miterlebt immer wieder
ich bin mit der Angst aufgewachsen in
meinem eigenen Schlafzimmer zu ertrinken
ich habe Angst vor der Zukunft ausgelöst
durch dieses Trauma die Klimakrise ist
real es sind nicht nur Überschwemmungen
oder Dürreperioden es ist Zerstörung
eine Zerstörung die Südasien Afrika und
die Karibik besonders hart trifft und
die Schulden Last ausgerechnet in jenen
Ländern in die Höhe treibt die ohnehin
kaum Mittel haben und für Kredite die
höchsten Zinsen zahlen die Zeit dränge
für eine neue finanzielle Solidarität
der Verursacher dieser Klimakrise mit
den Leidtragenden heißt es daher auf dem
Gipfel zu dem Frankreichs Präsident
macron nach Paris geladen hat
was wir nun in Zeiten einer erwachsenen
Kluft erreichen wollen ist eine neue
Übereinkunft die aber nicht nur von
einer Seite vorgegeben wird sondern von
denen erarbeitet wird die unter den
Folgen des Klimawandels leiden
Krieg
und so nehmen Vertreter von etwa 100
Staaten sowie internationalen
Organisationen teil
die globale Finanzarchitektur ist
veraltet das funktional und ungerecht
geworden sie ist nicht mehr in der Lage
den Bedürfnissen der Welt des 21
jahrhunderts gerecht zu werden
[Musik]
die Vereinten Nationen schätzen dass die
Entwicklungs- und Schwellenländer rund 2
Billionen Euro bräuchten um sich gegen
die Krise zu wappnen neben einer Reform
etwa das Internationalen Währungsfonds
geht es auch darum Konzerne mehr in die
Pflicht zu nehmen
wir fordern alle auf die Lasten zu
teilen damit wir den Gewinn teilen
können das bedeutet also dass es nicht
mehr ausreicht sich nur auf die
Regierungen zu verlassen
ein Forum für verbindliche Beschlüsse
ist das Pariser Treffen in das nicht es
ist ein erster Schritt auf den Wald der
nächste konkrete Folgen müsse so die
klimaaktivistin
sie können noch so viele Gipfel abhalten
wenn sie nichts für die Menschen tun die
am stärksten ausgegrenzt werden dann
bringt das alles nichts
dabei ging es nicht um gefährlichkeiten
der reichen Industrieländer sondern um
deren Verantwortung darum die Finanzwelt
neu zu ordnen bevor die Kosten der
Klimakrise ins Unermessliche steigen für
alle
ja ein Saal in dem viel geredet wird
jetzt kommt es darauf an was am Ende
rauskommt wir werden weiter berichten
Hannah du hast jetzt einen ersten
Überblick über das was heute auch noch
wichtig ist in seiner
Regierungserklärung zum anstehenden
EU-Gipfel hat sich Bundeskanzler Scholz
ganz auf die Außen und
Sicherheitspolitik konzentriert mit
Blick auf die Ukraine sagte er es habe
derzeit absolute Priorität die
tatsächliche Kampfkraft des Landes zu
stärken zudem soll weiter in die
Bundeswehr investiert werden
CDU-Chef mehr hat zwar Scholz vor dass
der anhaltende Streit innerhalb der
Bundesregierung die EU-Außenpolitik
ausbremse
außerdem beschloss der Bundestag heute
eine Reform der
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe wer eine Geld für
nicht zahlen kann oder will muss
deswegen nicht mehr so lange ins
Gefängnis wie bisher der Bundestag
entschied dass die Dauer halbiert werden
soll das bedeutet dass zwei verhängte
Tagessätze künftig nur noch einem Tag
Haft entsprechen
die Ukraine hat nach russischen Angaben
eine wichtige Brücke zu Halbinsel
krimschwer beschädigt die
john-haarbrücke die die Krim mit dem
festlandgebiet Person verbindet sei mit
Raketen beschossen worden und in den
kommenden Wochen nicht mehr zu benutzen
teilte der örtliche besatzungs-
das Bundessozialgericht hat erstmals
eine psychische Erkrankung im Grundsatz
als Berufskrankheit anerkannt geklagt
hatte ein Rettungssanitäter weil die
gesetzliche Unfallversicherung seine
posttraumatische Belastungsstörung nicht
als Berufskrankheit anerkannt hatte die
Kassler Richter betonten
Rettungssanitäter sein häufig besonders
belastenden Situationen ausgesetzt
Menschen mit einer anerkannten
Berufskrankheit erhalten medizinische
und finanzielle Unterstützung durch die
gesetzliche Unfallversicherung
die viertgrößte Stadt in Ostdeutschland
ist
Chemnitz heute Treffpunkt der
ost-regierungschefs mit dem
Bundeskanzler letztere musste sich
heftige Kritik anhören an den Plänen des
Bundes die Gelder für regionale
Wirtschaftsförderung zu kürzen im
kommenden Jahr wird in drei ostdeutschen
Bundesländern gewählt in allen drei
könnte die AFD nach derzeitigen Umfragen
stärkste Kraft werden das Vertrauen in
die Problemlösungskompetenz etablierter
Parteien sinkt die Zweifel an der
Demokratie nehmen zu auch das ergeben
Umfragen und zwar jeweils noch mal
besonders ausgeprägt im Osten
Deutschlands warum
aktuell sind gleich mehrere Bücher
erschienen die eine Kluft in diesem Land
beschreiben mehr als 30 Jahre nach der
Wiedervereinigung und eine Antwort
versuchen Christa Läpple
ein beschaulicher Vorort weit im Osten
Berlins hier lebt der Historiker Rainer
Eckert aus Protest gegen Putins Krieg
hat er frühere DDR Bürgerrechtler an
seinem Gartenzaun ein paar Finchen
angebracht ein kleines Signal mit großen
folgen
was ich erlebt habe war das die kleinen
ukraine-fähnchen zweimal abgeschnitten
wurden und die Nachbarn haben auch von
mir Fähnchen anbeten und haben die
wieder abgemacht und zwar aus Angst
und haben gesagt wir sind Anhänger vom
Putin wir wollen nicht dass die
ukrainische Fähnchen hängen Eckart hatte
in der DDR Berufsverbot unterkriegen
kommt für ihn nicht in Frage die
Fähnchen hatte wieder angebracht aber
was ist hier los fragt er sich mehr als
4 Milliarden Euro flossen in die DDR
Aufarbeitung in die Überwindung der
Diktatur das Ergebnis ist ernüchternd
nur noch jeder zweite ist im Osten
wieder Demokratie zufrieden wieder
dritte will AFD wählen und Putin hat
nirgendwo so viele Fans wie im Osten
Deutschlands für die junge Historikerin
Katja heuer hat die Unzufriedenheit
Gründe sie wagt einen neuen Blick auf
die DDR
die Erwartungen die es 1989 und 1990 gab
und die auch geschürt worden sind zu dem
Zeitpunkt weil man ja noch nicht wusste
was danach kommt
oftmals enttäuscht worden sind vor allem
was die wirtschaftliche Realität angeht
also man hat sich auch so lange ob das
jetzt über Westfernsehen ist oder über
Popmusik irgendwie an dem besten
orientiert den so gar nicht gab wie man
sich den vorgestellt hat und als dann
auf einmal sozusagen der Kapitalismus
kam mit allen seinen Chancen aber auch
allen seinen Risiken ist das für viele
schief gegangen wir sind das Volk heißt
es wieder wie 89 und dafür sind wir
nicht auf die Straße gegangen was für
die Linke an Protest eingesammelt hat
ist seit Flüchtlings Corona Ukraine und
inflationszeiten nach rechts abgewandert
ein toxisches Gemisch aus Wut und
Enttäuschung das nutzt der AFD
dazu kommt auch das einfach diese dieses
Gefühl irgendwie nicht dazu zu gehören
abgehängt zu sein irgendwie nicht Teil
der Gesellschaft zu sein ich gehört zu
werden unsere Revolution in der Regel
als sendete von mir hat
keine positiven keine revolutionsstolz
mit sich gebracht
vollende die Wände propagiert die AFD
für beide Historiker eine beispiellose
Verdrehung ein Treppenwitz der
Geschichte Katja heuer findet es lohnt
sich gerade jetzt für die Demokratie zu
streiten
ich würde einfach den Appell ansetzen
nicht den Kopf zu schütteln nicht die
Augen zu verdrehen es ist manchmal
schwierig und unter Umständen auch
schwierig zu ertragen weil man
vielleicht nicht unbedingt hören möchte
was andere gesagt wird aber die seid
Dialog ist wichtig der Austausch ist
wichtig der afd-aufstieg im Osten ist
ein Weckruf nicht alle Fehler der
letzten drei Jahrzehnte müssen
wiederholt werden
das war bis vor ein paar Stunden immer
noch ganz offiziell eine Rettungsmission
wenn auch eine zunehmenden verzweifelte
die Suche in den Tiefen des
Nordatlantiks nach dem vermissten tauch
U-Boot mit fünf Menschen an Bord die
Rettungsmannschaften aus drei Ländern
wollten die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben auch
wenn es kaum noch Hoffnung gab der
Sauerstoff an Bord ging zur Neige nach
manchen Berechnungen reichte er bereits
heute nicht mehr um Leben zu ermöglichen
und dann hat ein Suchroboter
Trümmerteile entdeckt die von dem U-Boot
stammen die Küstenwache geht
mittlerweile davon aus dass niemand
überlebt hat wenn er mir Daniel mit dem
neuesten Stand
nun ist es also klar die fünf Insassen
der Titen sind nicht mehr am Leben vor
wenigen Minuten gab die US-Küstenwache
eine Pressekonferenz
ein Tauchroboter hat weitere
Trümmerteile gefunden nach Rücksprache
mit unseren Experten sind es Überreste
der Druckkammer die auf katastrophale
Art und Weise zerstört worden ist
nach diesem klaren Ergebnis haben wir
umgehend die Angehörigen der Insassen
informiert
mittlerweile ist bekannt dass eine
Gruppe renommierter Meeresforscher
bereits vor fünf Jahren einen Brief an
ocean Gate geschickt hatte darin eine
Warnung vor den Risiken den die Firma
ihre Passagiere aussetzt Ingenieur Bad
Kämper war einer der Unterzeichner
es ist ein großes Experiment das keinen
Vorgaben folgt oder gesetzlich geregelt
ist sie segnen alles selbst ab das muss
nicht heißen dass das alles total falsch
ist es bedeutet aber dass man
Unsicherheiten in Kauf nimmt
die Verantwortung für diese
Unsicherheiten reicht das Unternehmen an
seine Kunden weiter wie sich Ocean Gate
juristisch absichert erzählt dieser
mexikanische Youtuber er hatte erst im
letzten Jahr an einer der Titanic
Exkursionen teilgenommen
wir mussten damals einen Vertrag
unterschreiben das waren ganz schön
viele Seiten darin wurde jedes mögliche
Risiko beschrieben auch dass wir dabei
sterben könnten wir alle wussten also
genau dass wir uns auf eine extrem
gefährliche Expedition lassen
die Suchaktion geht zwar weiter doch nun
mit dem Fund der Trümmerteile sind sich
viele Experten sicher die Crew war wohl
bereits am Sonntag tot
meine Kollegin Brigitte Saar
recherchiert seit 25 Jahren über
tiefsee-expeditionen sie war selbst vor
einigen Jahren mit einem tauch U-Boot
beim Wrack der Titanic und hat zwei der
Piloten interviewt die jetzt an Bord der
Titan waren muss man ja wohl sagen guten
Abend Brigitte es gibt wohl tatsächlich
keine Hoffnung mehr oder ja also die
Erkenntnisse heute sind eindeutig wenn
also Trümmerteile die zu dieser
Druckkammer zu diesen Kernbereich von so
einem U-Boot gehören gefunden wurden
dann gibt es keine Schutzzone mehr in
der noch Menschen sein können dann ist
dieses Tauchboot irgendwann an Sonntag
vermutlich dann implodiert
ja Brigitte was können wir denn jetzt
daraus schließen über das was wir heute
gesehen haben erlebt haben diese
Trümmerteile was möglicherweise passiert
ist
also es gibt jetzt im Moment mit der
Erkenntnis von heute gibt es zwei
denkbare Szenarien man hat ja vor
zwischen einer Stunde 45 und zwei
Stunden nach tauchbeginn den Kontakt zum
Schiff verloren zum zum Mini-U-Boot und
das muss ja dann im Prinzip schon der
Moment gewesen sein muss da irgendwie
Probleme gab und dann gibt's die
Variante das schon diese allerersten
Probleme so gravierend waren dass da an
der Stelle es einen Riss in diesem
Druckkörper gegeben hat und das Boot
schon explodiert ist möglicherweise noch
bevor es überhaupt am Meeresboden war
oder das ist da Probleme hat hatte dann
weiter in Richtung Meeresboden
abgesunken ist und weil man das Schiff
irgendwie nicht mehr steuern konnte weil
die Kapsel im Prinzip dann schon
führungslos war hat man auch nicht mehr
sanft abbremsen können bevor man am
Meeresboden aufsetzt ist also mit sehr
viel Wucht aufgesetzt und hat dabei
vielleicht die Kapsel so beschädigt dass
auch der Druck zu viel wurde und das
implodiert wurde diese zwei Szenarien
kann man sich mit den Trümmern die man
jetzt gefunden hat eigentlich noch
vorstellen ist denn das jetzt eine
Tragödie die irgendwann passieren musste
oder anders gefragt wie problematisch
war diese Konstruktion des
das ist schwer zu beurteilen weil wir ja
immer noch nicht wissen was da jetzt
genau versagt hat aber ja diese Kapsel
war im Vergleich zu den Kapseln anderer
Betreiber anderer Forschungsinstitute
die ja seit Jahren und damit eigentlich
auch sehr sicher Forschung und Tiefsee
Tauchgänge betreiben wirklich
signifikant anders alle anderen Kapseln
die wir so kennen hatten eine
Druckkammer die aus Metall war und die
als Kugel konzipiert war und eine Kugel
ist ein Körper der Druck sehr gut
verteilen kann und nun dachte man eben
man kann das anders machen das ist eine
Röhre die Druckverteilung auf der Röhre
ist anders und die Röhre war nicht aus
Metall sondern aus Carbonfasern
gewickelt und es gab vor zwei drei
Jahren als diese Kapsel auch in Dienst
gestellt wurde schon mal den Hinweis
dass der Druck bei diesen ständigen
Wechsel mal an der Oberfläche kein Druck
mal ganz tief im Wasser viel Druck
möglicherweise dazu führen könnte dass
es in diesen gewickelten Carbonfasern so
Mikro Risse gibt und die zwar am Anfang
gut hält aber möglicherweise über die
Jahre mit mehreren Einsätzen immer mehr
so mini Bruchstellen hat und mürbe wird
also es kann schon sein dass dieses
Konstrukt was physikalisch auf dem
Papier erstmal hält und was ja auch
mehrere Expeditionen durchgehalten hat
dass das am Ende doch das falsche war
für diesen permanenten krassen Wechsel
zwischen viel Druck und keinem Druck ist
dieses Unglück diese ganz
offensichtliche Tragödie jetzt das Ende
für den Tauchtourismus Titanic Wrack
vermutlich schon zum einen aus ganz
praktischen Gründen die Firma ist weg
das U-Boot ist weg der Firmengründer der
ja auch der treibende Mann hinter all
diesen Ideen war es weg und das zweite
ist natürlich welche Kunden will man
denn jetzt noch für so eine Tauchfahrt
begeistern also selbst wenn es jetzt ein
neues U-Boot gäbe dass man baut und das
für so einen kommerziellen Tauchgang
gemacht ist dann müsste man ja wieder
Abenteuer lustige Multimillionäre finden
die bereit sind da einzusteigen und
dafür Geld zu zahlen und ich gehe davon
aus dass die Warteliste für so eine
Expedition sehr kurz wäre auf der
anderen Seite möglicherweise gibt es ja
tatsächlich solche abenteuerlustigen
Multimillionäre tatsächlich noch da
schließlich noch eine Frage vielleicht
auch eine ganz persönliche Frage an dich
an Brigitte fragen sich ja viele
tatsächlich warum macht man sowas
überhaupt mit sich in so eine enge Röhre
zu zwingen 4000 Meter unter dem Meer wo
kann da die Faszination liegen
also man möchte natürlich mit eigenen
Augen dieses Frack erleben mit eigenen
Augen ist irgendwie immer intensiver als
Bücher zu sehen Fotos zu sehen
Dokumentationen zu sehen dieses
unmittelbare dort sein dabei sein in den
letzten Jahren gehört natürlich auch
dazu dass man damit dann vielleicht
irgendwie was darstellt ja in im
Zeitalter von Instagram und selbst
Inszenierung ist es natürlich auch etwas
was man nach der Reise womit man ein
bisschen angeben kann
aber die genaue Motivation eines jeden
Einzelnen ist eine andere für mich was
damals wirklich die Leidenschaft für
diesen diesen Teil der Geschichte aber
ich muss natürlich auch sagen als ich
getaucht bin gab es noch nie einen
tödlichen Vorfall mit den Insassen von
einer solchen Tiefsee Tauchkapsel und
das hat sich natürlich jetzt schlagartig
geändert das hat sich geändert auf jeden
Fall Brigitte sagt ganz herzlichen Dank
für diese hoch interessante Analyse auch
heute Abend wieder Danke Brigitte
so und jetzt hier in der Sendung noch
mal Hannah gestern schon Hannah haben
wir an dieser Stelle eine wichtige
Nachricht für Bahnreisende gehabt heute
gibt es deutlich mehr Details dazu ja
pünktlich zur Ferienzeit kam ja gestern
die Meldung dass die Gewerkschaft EVG
die Tarifverhandlungen mit der Deutschen
Bahn als gescheitert erklärt
unbefristete streiksdrohen ob sie
tatsächlich kommen das soll nun in einer
Uhr Abstimmung entschieden werden
Valerie Haller gerade mit Blick auf die
Ferien wann können Reisende mit einem
Ergebnis rechnen und was könnte auf Sie
zukommen unruhige Wochen könnte auf Sie
zukommen die Urabstimmung für einen
unbefristeten Streit die dauert vier bis
fünf Wochen sollte also Ende Juli
abgeschlossen sein ja aber bis dahin
sind dann trotzdem auch Warnstreiks
möglich vielleicht schon in den nächsten
Tagen oder Wochen und das treffe dann
Bahn Kunden zu einer der reisestärksten
Zeiten des Jahres aber soweit muss es
gar nicht kommen eine Einigung oder eine
Schlichtung ist noch drin die
Gewerkschaft sagt sie ist zu weiteren
Verhandlungen bereit aber die Bahn dann
noch mal ordentlich nachlegen der
Konflikt ist festgefahren die Bahn
spricht von einer unnötigen Eskalation
warum gelingt keine Einigung
nun da schieben sich jetzt wie in
tarifkonflikten üblich beide Seiten den
schwarzen Peter zu die Bahn kritisiert
den Abbruch der Gespräche jedenfalls
aufs schärfste sagt eine Einigung sei
zum Greifen nah gewesen und die EVG
hingegen die lehnt das Angebot der Bahn
ab so weit liegen die beiden Seiten in
einigen Punkten auseinander besonders
bei Lohn und Laufzeit die EVG fordert
650 € monatlich mehr die Bahn bietet 420
auch bei den Laufzeiten große
Differenzen die EVG vor der 12 Monate
die Bahn will 27 Monate da werden sich
beide Seiten also noch aufeinander zu
bewegen müssen wenn sie sich nicht
einigen dann droht ein Ausstand wie es
ihnen in Deutschland schon seit
Jahrzehnten nicht mehr gegeben hat
vielen Dank Valerie für diese
Einordnungen
das
Bundeskartellamt hat im Zusammenhang mit
der Energiepreis Bremse ein
Prüfverfahren gegen mehrere
Stromversorger eingeleitet dabei geht es
um die Frage ob sie überhöhte
Erstattungsanträge gestellt haben im Mai
hatte die Behörde bereits Verfahren
gegen mehrere Gas Versorger und
Fernwärme Anbieter eingeleitet werden
Verstöße festgestellt müssen die
Unternehmen die Gelder zurückzahlen
außerdem sind Bußgelder möglich
in der Türkei hat die Zentralbank wegen
der hartnäckig hohen Inflationsrate von
aktuell rund 40 Prozent einen
geldpolitischen Kurswechsel vollzogen
und den Leitzins kräftig angehoben von
8,5 auf 15 Prozent weil mit einem noch
größeren Schritt gerechnet wurde gab die
Lira nach und viel auf ein Rekordtief es
vor seiner Wiederwahl im Mai hatte
Präsident Erdogan sich selbst als
zinsfeind bezeichnet durch seine
Niedrigzinspolitik hatte die Lira massiv
an Wert verloren
die Zahl der einen Personen Haushalte in
Deutschland wird immer größer laut dem
Statistischen Bundesamt lebte 2022 in
knapp 41 Prozent der rund 40 Millionen
Haushalte in Deutschland nur eine Person
1950 lag der Anteil dagegen bei 19%. die
neuen Zahlen zeigen zudem dass im
vergangenen Jahr knapp die Hälfte der
allein lebenden ledig ein Viertel
verwitwett und 19% geschieden war
im Nordwesten von China sind bei einer
Gasexplosion in einem Restaurant
mindestens 31 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen bereits eine Stunde vor der
Explosion sollen Mitarbeiter einen
Gasgeruch bemerkt haben dennoch wurde
das Restaurant nicht evakuiert die
Polizei nahm neun Menschen fest darunter
auch den Restaurant Manager
Titelverteidiger deutschland ist mit
einer Enttäuschung in die U21
Fußball-Europameisterschaft gestartet
trotz 45-minütiger Überzahl reichte es
zum Auftakt gegen Israel im georgischen
kutatisi nur zu einem eins zu eins
Unentschieden nächster Gegner der
Deutschen ist Tschechien und auch kein
guter Tag für die deutschen
Tennisspieler beim ATP-Turnier in Halle
Westfalen verpasste Deutschlands
aktuelle Nummer eins Jan Lennart Strumpf
den Einzug ins Viertelfinale ebenso wie
Jannik hanfmann aus Karlsruhe und auch
für Jule Niemeyer kam beim WTA-Turnier
in Berlin das Aus im Achtelfinale die
23-Jährige war im zweiten Satz gegen die
Tschechien von aufs Handgelenk gefallen
spielte noch unter Schmerzen weiter gab
dann aber auf
[Applaus]
Preise steigen Wirtschaft schrumpft wird
Deutschland immer
ärmer fragt die Kollegin Maybrit Illner
gleich Ihre Gäste und da sind wir
natürlich dabei und wir weisen Sie
ausgegeben im Anlass natürlich auch noch
mal speziell auf den aktuellen
Wetterbericht hinten der läuft gleich
direkt nach uns ja und außerdem noch der
Hinweis auf unser heute journal Update
gegen 0:30 Uhr mit Gundula Gause von uns
allen hier Danke für heute gerne bis
morgen einen angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]
ja hallo und schönen guten Abend zum
Wetter wir haben es ja schon eben
gesehen es gab etliche Schauer und
Gewitter teils im unwetterbereich und im
extremen unwetterbereich des lag an dem
Tief Lambert was reingezogen ist und
sich morgen im Tagesverlauf allmählich
ostwärts bewegt und dann rausziehen wird
und wir sehen dahinter lockert es auf
und dann ist Schluss mit Unwettern aber
noch ist die Unwettergefahr groß vor
allem im Süden Deutschlands sehen wir da
kocht es regelrecht hoch hier sind
etliche Gewitter dabei die im extremen
unwetterbereich liegen mit Hagelsturm
und zu großen Regenmengen in kurzer Zeit
das ganze verlagert sich langsam nach
Nordosten aber wir sehen auch hier
Richtung Magdeburg da ist ordentlich
Regen dabei und Berlin wird gerade vom
nächsten Regengebiet erfasst aber wir
sehen auch hier nach Norden den da
regnet es kräftig im Wissen ebenfalls
also das geht noch diese Nacht weiter
und bis morgen schauen wir uns noch die
Nacht kurz an also nach Norden also
teilweise viel Regen und auch orkanböden
die können dabei sein bei heftigen
Gewittern Temperaturen gehen zurück auf
20 Grad im Osten Deutschlands sehr mild
und 13 Grad im hessischen Bergland
morgen also noch vor allem am Vormittag
noch Schauer und Gewitter verlagert sich
allmählich ostwärts und von Westen er
lockerts auf da zeigt sich die Sonne
schon Temperaturen nicht mehr dazu hoch
wie heute 28 Grad im Rhein-Main-Gebiet
und 19 Grad in der Ostsee und die
schwule ist dann auch endlich weg und
die nächsten Tage nun das Wochenende
bleibt größtenteils trocken und sonnig
und Montag kommt der neue Gewitter von
Westen her und damit ein schöner Abend